Sophia Ricci photographed facetiming
with Scott Disick I think she's pretty
good the 18 year old daughter of Lionel
Richie and little sister of Nicole
Richie made headlines in May when she
and the reality star were spotted
looking flirty on a yacht in kanne Sofia
later took to Twitter to squash any
romance rumors just so everyone can get
their panties out of there Scott and I
are just homies but on Thursday the
model was photographed facetiming with
Kourtney Kardashian's ex after arriving
at LAX Scott could be seen on her iPhone
smiling ear-to-ear and rocking some
shades do you see other people at the
moment no you don't hmm
I mean I technically could I yes yeah
totally the teen was just one of a
string of women the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star was spotted cozying up
to while in the South of France he was
later seen engaging in some serious PDA
with 19 year old Bella Thorne who later
tweeted that she is quote not talking to
Scott or anyone else hashtag don't [ __ ]
with it
you